Transcriptor: Emma Gon
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Qué cosa maravillosa
es desvelarse sabiendo
que el día siguiente
no te tienes que levantar temprano.
Que podrás remolonear toda la mañana
sin que ningún ruido
impertinente te perturbe.
Qué maravilla servirte una copa de vino,
poner la música fuerte,
sola o acompañada, pero libre.
Qué rico acomodar los bocaditos,
oler cada uno antes de comerlo,
sin pausa, pero sin prisa.
Luego el silencio de la mañana
y esa sensación de levantarte pero no,
de incorporarte pero todavía,
de encariñarte con tus sábanas
ya aclimatadas a tu cuerpo.
El goce del tiempo propio,
de ese que puedes gastar sin culpas.
Mi frase de confort es:
“Me lo merezco”.
Para esto trabajo, para mí,
para engreírme, para poder vivir cómoda.
De verdad me lo merezco.
Ya me he preguntado varias veces
si no quiero casarme y tener hijos.
¿Eres mujer? ¿Mayor de 18 años?
No te salvas.
¡No vayas a decir que no!
Igual te van a fregar
y fregar con el tema,
Pero como yo soy
un poco buscapleitos,
siempre voy y de frente digo no,
no quiero tener hijos,
razón principal soy libre.
No quiero ser responsable
de nada más allá de mis fronteras.
Quiero dedicarme a madurar,
a crecer, a aprender.
¿Qué tendría yo
que enseñarle a otra persona?
No podría decirles
que elegí ser periodista
porque realmente creo que así nací.
Pero cuando decidí ser reportera,
una de las primeras cosas
que vino anclada fue:
nada de hijos.
Algo así como la etiqueta
que venía con la chamba.
Es indispensable poder decir,
yo puedo viajar sin saber
cuándo voy a volver.
Pero un día la vida que me merezco
dejó de acomodarse,
si fuera religiosa diría epifanía.
Pero prefiero decir
que fue como un golpe de electricidad.
De pronto la casa era demasiado grande.
El auto se sentía vacío y
las noches demasiado silenciosas.
Yo que dije, nunca,
que me sentía cómoda
y completa en mi piel,
no me reconozco más.
Un rayo feroz sonó dentro de mí
y una frase salió de mis entrañas:
“Quiero ser mamá, pero quiero más”.
Quiero una familia,
así como una necesidad visceral.
Cuidado pues, que pases por mi puerta,
podría ser elegido más veloz
que ministro o congresista
y con menos preguntas
sobre tus calificaciones.
Vamos, sé mi esposo.
Hagamos una familia.
Quiero ser mamá.
Y un día de abril llego Doménica.
La nombré Sol de mi universo.
Y entonces descubrí que nunca eres
la mamá que pensabas que ibas a ser.
No estaba preparada para que las emociones
fueran siempre tan exageradas,
para sentir pánico
desde el primer momento.
No estaba preparada
para llorar cada uno de los días
que mi bebé pasó en
la clínica en cuidados intermedios
para torturarme extrayéndonme leche
en una carrera frenética
contra mí misma.
La maternidad fue una explosión
que me deshizo en mil pedazos
que nunca más volverían a juntarse.
Hace tan solo un año,
yo era tan buena para dormir;
por estos días solo veo el valor
en cada uno de los minutos
que paso al lado de mi bebé,
que crezca, que esté sana, que florezca
cada gota de mí se va en ello.
De pronto, los días se dividen
entre el amor tan intenso
que me duele, los cuidados y la culpa.
Cada cosa que mi bebé necesita,
la necesita de mí.
Me avergüenza confesar que alguna vez
dije que mi mamá no trabajaba.
Perdóname, mamá.
Y gracias por responder a
cada una de mis llamadas
y cruzar toda la ciudad para venir
a calmar mis angustias y miedos.
Mamá también necesita de su propia mamá,
una cadena de cuidados para mantener
con vida  a una pequeña persona.
Conmigo duerme mejor.
Es mi leche su mayor alimento.
Sólo yo sé cómo le gusta
el agua de la tina.
De tanto repetírmelo se hizo realidad
y un día, por fin, me sentí competente.
Ese mismo día dije,
“No tendré más hijos”,
pero la vida está llena
de giros inesperados.
Y así ocurrió en medio de
la dolorosa ruptura de mi matrimonio,
estaba embarazada por segunda vez.
Ahí, de pie, con una barriga
de cinco meses
y una hija de tres años,
frente a una casa vacía.
Dos hijos pequeños y un adulto a cargo
sin duda es una mala ecuación.
Su energía en contraste
de mi agotamiento,
el postparto, el postdivorcio,
la enorme responsabilidad.
Entonces supe lo que eran
interminables noches de angustia.
Ya no me acuerdo el sabor de ese vino.
No hay música.
Con suerte no hay llanto.
Pero ya saben que con dos niños
en casa casi nunca hay suerte.
Pero dentro de una vida caben muchas.
Y las piezas que volaron tras la explosión
no vuelven al mismo lugar,
pero se acomodan.
Gracias, Cayetano
por llegar y recomponerme,
tu amor me salvó.
Pero luego tocaba volver
al trabajo, dejar a los niños.
Y entonces mi madre, las tías, las nanas.
Tantas espaldas de mujer
soportando las labores de cuidado
que permiten que gire el mundo.
Mi mundo giraba por ellas.
Ya saben, ese trabajo invisible,
ese por el que nadie paga,
¿alguna de sus madres o
abuelas recibió un sueldo
o una pensión  por cuidarlos, criarlos
y hacerlos personas
durante todas sus vidas?
Las labores de cuidado de niños,
ancianos o personas con discapacidad
son justamente parte de
ese trabajo invisible y no remunerado
que es realizado
mayoritariamente por mujeres.
Ese trabajo no remunerado a nivel mundial
representa el 9 % del
Producto Bruto Interno,
según la Organización
de las Naciones Unidas
para la igualdad de género y
el empoderamiento de la mujer.
En términos de horas dedicadas
a la semana, según ONU Mujeres,
se estima que invertimos
tres veces más horas que los hombres
para el desarrollo de estas actividades.
Pero yo sé que me van a decir
que los hombres ahora participan más
y es cierto.
Desde el año 1997 al 2012,
la brecha de género
ha disminuido  en 7 minutos diarios,
ya saben, 7 minutos más
al día para nosotras,
una ducha como mucho.
Bueno, sobre ese trabajo invisible
se sostenía la vida de muchas mujeres
en un equilibrio precario
que no estaba preparado
para un giro fatal de la historia.
Un virus contagioso
nos obligó a encerrarnos.
El mundo cerró sus puertas y nos quedamos
con todo el peso sobre los hombros
y ahora solas.
Las redes que nos sostenían
debían cortarse por completo,
sin colegios, sin ayuda
en casa, sin guarderías.
¿Cómo haces tú para trabajar
sin ninguna red de cuidados?
¿Cómo puedes seguir las clases virtuales,
tu trabajo, tus reuniones
y hacer las compras
para tener comida en casa?
¿Puede la sociedad funcionar
sin esa red de cuidados?
Primera realidad para mí:
sin ayuda en casa no puedo trabajar.
Entonces, nuevamente, las espaldas
de mujeres sosteniendo al mundo.
Yo tuve que volver a la casa
de mi mamá, pedirle refugio,
y esas dos semanas
que se convertían en 15 días más
y otros 15 días más.
La estadía se fue prolongando y
convirtiéndose en un campamento
en innumerables noches,
durmiendo con dos pequeños
en un colchón inflable
viendo películas en una laptop
y jugando a las sombras
de animales con las manos.
Los niños son seres maravillosos.
Doménica y Cayetano
fueron mis maestros
para aprender a disfrutar
de las pequeñas cosas.
Ellos se acomodan a todo,
pero los adultos no,
nos cuesta mucho más;
aun en medio de esa angustia,
descubrí que era afortunada.
Yo tuve una red de cuidados y apoyo.
Tuve a mi madre para cuidar a los niños.
Cuando salía en jornadas de trabajo
de 12 horas vestida como astronauta
y embargada de miedos, pero miles
de mujeres con labores de cuidado
no tuvieron a nadie.
Es por eso que la tasa de
participación laboral de mujeres
cayó hasta un 45 %
En los meses de pandemia,
se han retrocedido 16 años en
participación laboral femenina,
sin colegios, sin guarderías,
sin apoyo en casa.
Entonces, en el silencio de la cuarentena,
me detuve a pensar en
aquellas historias que vi como periodista.
Recordé la historia de la doctora
que trae niños al mundo
en medio de tanta muerte,
que no ve a su única nieta hace meses,
que está aislada para proteger
a su familia de los contagios.
Pensé también en las enfermeras
que morían de terror,
cuando regresaban a casa
a preparar la comida para sus hijos,
porque después de
infinitas horas de guardia,
las labores en casa no desaparecen.
Cada vez que iba a trabajar, estaban ahí
también, las señoras de limpieza,
las más invisibles entre
las trabajadoras esenciales,
las más expuestas, las más recias,
las que se despiertan de madrugada
para dejar cocinada
la comida para sus niños,
que ojalá sean lo suficientemente
grandes para estar solos
mientras ellas regresan.
Conversar con ellas, enmascaradas
todas con miedo y cansadas,
era descubrir que muchas de nuestras
angustias parten del mismo lugar,
porque incluso en medio del terror,
estábamos pensando siempre
en nuestros hijos.
Quizás la pandemia nos ha dañado de
una manera que aún no logramos procesar.
Nos ha puesto frente
al espejo de nuestros miedos,
pero también frente a
la realidad de lo desigual
que se reparte el peso de
las labores de cuidado en el mundo.
Yo, Leah Sacin Gabancho, periodista
de profesión, feminista y luchadora,
he vivido muchas vidas en 36 años,
Fui una exitosa soltera,
fui esposa y madre,
divorciada y embarazada,
fui sobreviviente de
la pandemia con dos niños.
Todas esas vidas me trajeron hasta aquí
y pues hoy soy la que ven con los kilos,
las ojeras y la salud mental de quien
siempre anda debiendo horas de sueño.
Pero soy una sobreviviente porque fue el
amor el que tejió una red que me sostuvo.
Pero así como creo en el amor,
creo también en que no podemos
seguir ignorando el trabajo invisible
que mantiene al mundo girando.
Creo que es el momento de dar
el gran salto hacia algo tan sencillo
que parece increíble tener que decirlo.
Igualdad en la carga
de trabajo no remunerado,
porque en el día a día, en los hogares,
en la crianza de los niños
o el cuidado de los ancianos
hay muchísimo  trabajo invisible
que descansa mayoritariamente
en las espaldas de mujeres
por las millones
que murieron sin ser reconocidas.
Ellas no necesitan un homenaje,
necesitan que las cosas cambien.
Con esa fuerza les propongo
transformar el hogar
que se merecen todas
esas mujeres que lo sostienen,
por nosotras, pero en especial
por las que se van yendo
y por las que vienen detrás.